and we're back we are now at Jonathan
hare of web Shield Inc thank you for
joining us and you co-founded it and
maybe it's just a little bit about this
why is it so important
well web Shield we're a software company
and we're basically eliminating the
crisis of trust in the internet which is
how do you allow any person or
organization contribute resources they
have their data their algorithms the
right to use their brand their contracts
or infrastructure pull it with other
people that they don't agree with trust
even know to create value-added and
things like personalized health networks
that reduce the cost of health care by
30 percent
yet are more convenient and deliver
better outcomes yes right now there's
this issue of trust and it's because I
have data that could be classified as
volle neural and I want to not only
anonymously give that data because then
they can leverage it for better use and
decreased costs and all those other
great things but also you're not even
just anonymizing you're making it look
like gibberish absolutely we call the
quantum privacy network really the
underlying issue with the internet my
opinion is if you're talking about
policy enforcement or security it's
organized around enterprises their
applications they're encrypting it so
they hold the keys to the data right
it's not organized it doesn't understand
what a person is there's no way to link
a person to records about them or
establish trust between them and other
people so we've done is committed a
whole new paradigm for the for the
internet it's called the quantum privacy
network that allows you to take any
resource whether it's data or algorithms
or a computing infrastructure or what
have you
publish to the network
and it we link it to what we call trust
criteria and Trust credentials so trust
Court I are you know regulatory
compliance has to be HIPAA compliant
according to Enoch has to be
cybersecurity in this organization
payment and licensing terms I'll give
you my data but I want personalized you
know patient safety systems work back
before those patients authorised
recipients my doctors can see it in
their staff but only these views not
everybody in the doctor I happen to be
visitor in the hospital I happen to be
visiting we also published some trust
criteria about what is this data or this
resource where's it come from why do I
trust it how has it been transformed
this all gets combined and we write it
to what we call it proof of trust
blockchain so 50 years out from now you
can figure this data came from this
hospital with these credentials with
these criteria and then you can
basically combine that with other
people's resources right without
revealing it to anybody the property
network takes it and as you said
transforms an obvious gated gibberish so
it's what the NSA calls flat data it's
got no meaningful structure you can't
learn anything from it that's hashing
it's one form of it we actually is the
new thing privacy algorithms are very
very different
that's the novelty but you can do any
computation any policy enforcement
without revealing any information to any
organization or person the trust
criteria and Trust credentials you link
to your resource are automatically
inherited by anything derived by it so
if you take data from thousands
different sources and you run it through
some of these data models and you run on
somebody's computing platform and
somebody runs somebody's clinical
algorithms on it those are all different
resources they all have their own trust
criteria and anything derived from that
like personalized decision support
presented to this nurse before this
patient it inherits all this trust
criteria and it won't resolve it into a
meaningful view that this nurse or
anybody else can understand unless all
the trust criteria have everything
that's contribute our first satisfied
and that means people can pool their
resources with people they don't even
know or trust they don't have to agree
on policies they don't have to like each
other you know and it creates this
global network effect where everybody is
the center of their own universe they
have their own what we call privacy
domain yeah you're in charge all the
data about you since you actually have a
legal right to it we enforce that right
so data can
be pulled for your benefit you get paid
for it
then maybe you can get universal basic
income from your data absolutely or you
just get much better healthcare outcomes
without paying or at least much money
money much more convenience right now to
make you smarter at work you can get
educated better so it has all these
benefits but it's and you don't it's not
like well jeez what's Facebook can do
with my data
um they never had it they can deliver
value to you but they don't have access
to your data for the same time it's like
well what good is your data if it's not
connected to anybody else's data what
you want to do is I want to learn about
how to have better health care outcomes
in a better life by analyzing my data
combined with everybody else
exactly Yeah right I was like well you
can do that too and nobody will see your
data submitting it so then let's let's
give some examples so you give the the
health example so I can give my
biometric data in AI and that's
completely obfuscated they can't see Who
I am what it is at all until there's a
there's a proof of trust right and then
it shows that that proof of trust
enables it to how does that work how
does it show so in your resource when
you want to take a data from your same
personal privacy domain which is under
your control even you don't have the
keys because you shouldn't trust
yourself with your own keys good you're
gonna lose them so nobody can see your
data at all it's like oh I want to
contribute to this global patient safety
Network mm-hmm
this can analyze everybody's do it
against everybody else's figure out
what's gonna work for me so I'm not
running Hunkin experiments on myself
with my doctor right I'm saying well go
from the hospital visit into your
we great we're called privacy pipe so it
takes the data and it runs the thro
network that basically it's fairly
technical but we clip to a hash that we
tokenizing we randomized it and we
purchase and data is all scatter all
over the place everything is you know a
sort of opaque
it's either encrypted it's tokenized
it's randomized and it's scattered all
over the place so to the computers like
I don't even know what this is or where
it came from but we have in there the
description of the data the trust
credentials which include the schema
definition the terminologies the rules
all that information is there so the
network and these other privacy mains
they got hot I want to do this clinical
research so I know what this algorithm
is that's another resource we understand
what its data model is what its
terminology understands and so on so the
network can map it into that format feed
it to so it can do its computation but
it's running in a privacy main that
nobody's got the keys to right so you
know you don't have to trust that
company or that enterprise or that
government agency with your data don't
have control of it without yourself what
you can do is like aha so now this
network this is global clinical research
network discovered a cure for cancer
that I happen to be suffering from it
figures out exactly which combination of
therapies for someone with my genome
with my treatment history my behavioral
lifestyle issues and everything else
about me here's what you need to do so
we'll give messages my doctor what my
doctor needs to do they'll tell me what
I need to know about changing behavior
and so on but that only shows up saying
my cell phone I can see what I need to
know but I don't need to know my whole
genome I don't need to see about my my
history of heroin abuse on my phone it
just gave me what I'm supposed to do to
keep me healthy same thing my doctor
right ok so then I'm just getting a
recommendation about how to be healthier
based on all of the new data sets that
are being made
and then I'm able to contribute data as
I as it makes sense through my current
state it gives you basically decisions
and you know it's a advice or
information about you based on
everything about you but everything
about everybody else right gives you
advice you respond and then the network
learns how does that work out it's just
a global intelligence and that's why we
call it quantum privacy because we
eliminate the conflict between privacy
and sharing and pooling because well we
all need these it would be nice if we
had everybody's data analyze it yeah
that's a good way if we didn't care
about privacy or laws or contracts right
so this thing says okay we deal with
privacy and security but at the same
time you can pull do any work at any
value yeah right and then the ability to
measure value it's like hey guess what
we learned out that this person did
better than expected this population we
cut the cost of health care by 30
percent we had better out health care
outcomes we'll pay for that
we'll pay you based on your actual
results and every person is telling
control their own data they can have any
doctor they want they you can have you
know your your cell phone tell you what
you need to do why am I even talking to
a doctor why am I in his office or her
office I'm just learning what I need to
know how to look better as I'm living my
life this is another one of those things
that brings me back to making me feel
like I'm a five-year-old because I have
no really solid understanding of and I'm
only baby stepping into it and it's
really important it's really important
this is what a horizontal marketplace
would look like for data right rather
than a vertically integrated one and
that that would be great to combine all
these data and without the feeling that
people have when they give their data is
am I actually trusting this this source
to say that they are encrypting it in a
special way that is that they they don't
see the data they don't own the data
that they promised that right not then
the
and location that it's going to also
isn't going to to know that it's
actually mine and that they're able to
use it for their data sets and make
relevant recommendations to me and other
people like me so that seems to be this
like general gist but that that first
step of just being able to trust right I
mean what we're doing I mean that's a
good insight and you know we we have
like big data and things like consumer
entertainment because there's basically
no privacy laws there he's like yeah
what the heck all that Facebook habit
I'll let Google have it right but we
need to do something like health care
which is highly sensitive regulated
dated everybody uses as sort of
proprietary everything these tiny little
silos and we have a completely
dysfunctional system and people are
dying every day yes information mistakes
and there's no way to learn what cures
what it's a disaster it's it's so the
privacy network says we bacon a level
privacy that's so beyond any law
regulations ever required I mean we're
talking many orders acting more robust
like we we claim will make it more than
million times more secure mind is fully
rolled out and you know big statement
it's like yeah let's get it tested
yeah it's get it certified Yeah right
and it's like gosh since you can pull
data without revealing to anybody all
those privacy issues are irrelevant
because nobody can see my data yet they
can give me back personalized just as a
sport so to a consumer is really simple
right it's like I don't even have to
understand where this data is I get to
make my own choices I get better you
know information lower prices I'm happy
I don't have to trust them to go with my
data right
also we're getting the network assessed
and certified to verify that it's
compliant with all these laws and
regulations right yeah and not only that
turns out you as a consumer you actually
have a right to all your data of course
but you can't prove that you have the
right so in fact you can't get it so
once we get the network certified and
we're working with organizations that
have enough data to basically you know
get the network's a critical mass so you
can it knows where your data is then you
can assert your rights like hey I want
my own personal health network get all
the data deliver me and I can choose
services I want that work better for me
and there'll be a just an immediate
change once that we get the network
basically certified and I think there's
so much frustration out there with the
current system it's so completely broken
you know once you have something
actually works there's nothing really to
understand yeah I don't know how my cell
phone works but I can use it you know I
don't know how lack of how many people
know how encryption works yeah and it's
like they shouldn't trust it but they do
for like banking transactions they
didn't originally trust it but once it's
up and running so that's our strategist
get the network stood up get the key
players that know how broken is come up
with solutions it's really robust we
also have by the way the ep-3 foundation
yeah which is empowering people of
privacy and personalization so that's a
501c3 nonprofit it's made up we have
like 100 fellows and trustees it's open
to everyone and it's like hey do you
believe in giving people deep
personalization and control yeah with
absolute privacy yeah and that allows us
to bring it work you know bring in all
the different organizations we're doing
a whole bunch of launched initiatives
around the hardest privacy problems we
can find Wow
yeah but hey it's awesome you see what
yeah you totally seem like the real deal
with this absolute privacy yeah if you
don't have that you have nothing yeah
why we do so I don't want everybody at
my data yeah yeah example it's not just
privacy it's like I invested in that
data yeah and you want me to give it to
you and and I socialize it then why
would people invest if they don't get
any value but I'm following the brothers
not always money I'm not a big fan of
selling data it's like I don't want
people buying or selling my data yeah
yeah but it's like I'll let you have all
day about me and you can offer me
services back yeah I'll take better
health care that's much cheaper so you
save me a lot more than ever for to pay
yeah
save me thousands of dollars a year yeah
and you know it was like that's a lot
more than Facebook gets from their data
totally you know by the way we'll saw
Facebook's problem as well it's like
just give your very own personal privacy
to me why do you want their data do you
want the keys to their do you understand
what they're doing do you want to say
just they will still be able to
advertise them to you because they know
what you how you're behaving is just
that they don't own it yeah they don't
rush yeah I think that's a bird control
and access other people people won't
trust you it's like what are you going
to do with my data
yeah and by the way Facebook right now
is beautiful company all they have is an
advertising revenue model
and that whole attention economy getting
kids and people's yeah addicted their
phones that's not healthy it's like what
if you use that vast beautiful Network
and you can contribute to better
healthcare outcomes and making people
smarter work and better educated there's
a lot more value there will give them
that revenue model if you want to make
more money from advertising to because
you know if you put consumers control
their data they have rights the data
that you be tortured and killed for even
talking about using for advertising and
it's like yeah you don't see my data you
give me better services you find the
right doctor free right services you
make my life convenient you know there's
plenty of money here and that's a lesson
the googles and the Facebook's of top
the world is free is key to ubiquity so
if you can make something free but there
what you're doing is like you're giving
up your privacy and exchange for some
consumers yeah and there's like what if
you're not giving out privacy and it's
so or bust that even the most regulated
to sensitive proprietary data would
literally be illegal to you can now get
the benefit of and you can pull with
everybody else that's valued that is
value yeah awesome this has been a very
good first step for me and for some of
the people that are watching into this
domain of knowledge really it's a it's a
really important one that's coming into
play with general data privacy rights
and and what we've seen with Cambridge
analytic and Facebook but also with all
these biometrics and how they're
applicable for decreasing the cost of
overall healthcare having large datasets
to actually run machine learning on to
be able to make these predictive
analytics this is all super important
and just time has come time is coming
there's just that feeling of like I got
a trust when I'm checking the box that
you are going to keep it a hundred
percent out of your hands and out of the
hands of everybody else in a way that
they know that it's mine but in a way
they can still leverage it for for
beneficial purposes that's one of the
reasons why we created the ep-3
foundation because I don't think it's
appropriate any commercial entity to
have control of something like the
internet yeah our my data yeah so it's
really organized around people but also
neutral nonprofits yes that provide
governance already and then basically in
our world you decide who you trust you
need to agree with anybody but it
creates a market for trust where if
you're not trustworthy people just say I
don't trust them anymore
turn them off correct there yet yeah
right so it rewards trust Trust enables
sharing exactly pooling of resources
which is worth more money so everybody
wins Yeah right
I hear that yeah exactly that's that a
good behavior incentivization right yeah
yeah let me make sure the tragedy of the
Commons and there's so many issues that
surround that's the reason why we focus
on healthcare by the way because it's
more than ten years I started working on
this particular thing and it's like to
solve healthcare it's the hardest
possible problem but unless we solve
these fundamental issues it will be
completely broken right and also if
we're gives you the opportunity to solve
these privacy issues to get you access
extremely sensitive data that the
consumer guys like Facebook they don't
know anything about that data but once
you solve this fundamental problem it
actually applies everywhere right
consumer entertainment social network
and employees everywhere work how does
that security thing work now in cyber
security we have that cracked privacy
issues right so we see it coming out in
all these domains more or less at the
same time and the technicalities are
tough but I'm going to learn them over
time and hopefully we can communicate
them to more people over time this is a
good beginner session Jonathan I really
appreciate you joining us on the show my
pleasure yeah thank you very much and
we'll see you guys more take every she
ate it